Japón es un país que puede presumir de
dos cosas: la primera es que tienen
máquinas expendedoras de ropa interior
usada por la calle; la segunda es que
tienen la tasa de inmigración más baja
de todo el mundo desarrollado. Para que
os hagáis una idea, un país como
España tiene un 14 por ciento de
población inmigrante, Canadá o Nueva
Zelanda tienen un 20 en un 25 por ciento
respectivamente.
Pues bien, Japón no llega ni siquiera al
2%.
Esto se explica porque tienen una de las
leyes de inmigración más restrictivas
que existen. En otras palabras, Japón
sería el país perfecto para Donald
Trump o Marine Le Pen. Y ¿por qué os vamos
a hablar de Japón hoy? Si hay algo que
ha caracterizado, al menos políticamente,
el año 2016 ha sido la palabra
inmigración. En Europa el debate sobre los
refugiados todavía sigue abierto y
parece que la opinión mayoritaria es
que los inmigrantes son un problema que
hay que frenar; que nuestros gobiernos no
pueden dedicarse a gastar dinero para
mantener a eso que llaman:
- "la presión migratoria. ahora mismo está"
"la presión migratoria" "entre 2008 y 2014 Estados
Unidos casto 128.000 millones en el
control de la inmigración"
"es que el buenismo en este punto tiene sus límites".
Pues bien,
Japón es el ejemplo perfecto de lo que
significa vivir en un país sin
inmigrantes. Y os preguntaréis ¿qué
efectos tiene esto en su economía?
¿Realmente consiguen ahorrar dinero al no
tener que pagar todas estas políticas
de integración para los inmigrantes? ¿Es
fácil encontrar un trabajo para los
japoneses al no tener que competir con
la mano de obra extranjera?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a explicar en
qué consiste la ley de inmigración
japonesa.
Esta frase fue pronunciada por el que
fue Primer Ministro de Japón a mediados
de los años 80, Yasuhiro Nakasone
y condensa a la perfección la política
de inmigración de Japón.
Básicamente hay dos formas de entrar en
el país del sol naciente con un
contrato de trabajo bajo el brazo o con
un visado de turista. Y si una empresa
decide contratarte desde el extranjero
aún necesitas un visado y ese visado
solo te lo darán si tienes una
titulación universitaria de alto nivel.
Algo tan específico y tan cualificado
que sea prácticamente imposible de
encontrar en el mercado laboral japonés.
Si por ejemplo eres un trabajador de la
construcción te va a resultar
prácticamente imposible entrar en el
país, a no ser que te acojas a este otro sistema:
- "Bien, Japón como no tenía otra
forma de aceptar a profesionales venidos
de países tercermundistas, asiáticos,
como puede ser Vietnam o Filipinas, creó
un sistema especial de entrenamiento que
le llaman el Technical Inter Training Programme,
En resumen es como
si te fueras a trabajar de becario a
Japón pero cobrando la mitad del sueldo
que cobraría un becario japonés.
Pero no sólo eso, es que además con este
"programa de entrenamiento técnico"
tu jefe puede requisarte tu pasaporte y
hasta acceder a tu cuenta bancaria.
Es más, desde que se ha empezado  a poner
en marcha este plan
miles de inmigrantes asiáticos han
desaparecido
- "Cuando el representante del sindicato
habló conmigo, me dijo que tenía una
mala actitud y que si continuaba así
su amiga contrataría a un sicario para
matarme".
Pero ¿qué pasa si entras con un
visado de turista?
Pues bien en este caso te puedes quedar
en Japón durante un año y medio
siempre y cuando puedas demostrar que
estás estudiando japonés. Una vez ha
pasado este tiempo necesitas que una
empresa japonesa te contraté para tener
tu visado, pero, ojo, a diferencia de otros
países como Estados Unidos o la Unión
Europea, esté visado incluye también tu
categoría profesional. Es decir, que si
tienes un visado para ser chef de cocina
en Japón, no puedes trabajar de otra
cosa que no sea un chef de cocina.
De otro modo no volverán a renovarte el
permiso, así que desde el punto de vista
práctico
sólo hay un método para poder vivir en Japón:
-"Lo más fácil que tenemos
aquí al menos en Japón para residir es
casarse con una japonesa".
Así que ahora entendemos cómo es posible que en un
país que tiene más de 127 millones de
habitantes sólo dos millones sean
extranjeros.
Ahora, vamos a ver qué consecuencias
tiene esto en el día a día de los
japoneses
Japón es el país más anciano de la
historia.
Esto no es porque tengan una larga
historia, que la tienen, sino porque su
media de edad es la más alta del mundo.
De hecho, se estima que en sólo 90 años
habrán perdido a más de 44 millones de
habitantes que es casi la población de
España.
En principio esto no tendría por qué
ser ningún problema si no fuera por la
seguridad social.
Como sabéis, en casi todos los países
del mundo el sistema de pensiones
funciona de tal forma que los que están
trabajando en este momento son los que
están pagando las pensiones de los
jubilados de hoy en día.
Si la población activa decrece año tras
año, cada vez hay menos gente pagando
las pensiones y más gente cobrándolas,
y eso explica cosas como está:
- "Las contribuciones a la seguridad social
sólo cubren el 60 por ciento del gasto
en pensiones.
El resto viene de impuestos".
Por cierto, que esto tan bonito que está
sonando es la música de "Mescalina" un
grupo de rock de León, en España que
nos ha enviado su música.
Si os gusta, encontraréis más links en
la descripción
No solo eso, Japón está subiendo
sus cotizaciones a la seguridad social
año tras año. Lo mismo pasa con los
impuestos, y sin embargo siguen siendo
incapaces de hacer frente a sus gastos.
De hecho, a día de hoy, Japón es el
país con más deudas del mundo. Su deuda
equivale a más de dos veces su producto
interior bruto y su déficit fiscal, es
decir la diferencia entre lo que ingresa
y lo que gasta, es más alto incluso que
el de España.
En una palabra: como Angela Merkel se
pase un día por Japón les va a echar una
bronca que ni te cuento. Y os preguntareis
¿esto qué tiene que ver con la
inmigración? Pues mucho.
Todos hemos oído hablar de lo caro que
resulta acoger a inmigrantes en un país
¿verdad? Hay que pagarles cursos de
integración, políticas sociales, etcétera.
Pero se habla muy poco de lo que cuesta
un ciudadano local.
Por ejemplo, un ciudadano español desde
que nace hasta que cumple los 16 años
le cuesta al estado más de 132.000
euros.
Todo esto es solamente lo que gasta en
colegio y médicos.
A esto habría que sumarle otro tipo de
gastos. Es decir, que el estado invierte
en cada ciudadano un montón de dinero
que sólo empezará a recuperar el día
en el que esa persona pueda empezar a
trabajar y pagar impuestos, que en
España como mínimo son los 16 años.
Sin embargo, un inmigrante que llega a un
país, ya ha pasado por el colegio y ya
ha pasado por la consulta del pediatra.
Y en alrededor de dos años de media
encontrará un trabajo. Por supuesto que
muchos de esos empleos tienen una baja
cualificación y están mal remunerados
por lo tanto el estado recibe muy
poquito dinero de los impuestos, pero
como no ha tenido que hacer
prácticamente ninguna inversión es
prácticamente dinero gratis para los
gobiernos. Como Japón no tiene inmigrantes
pierde esa oportunidad de recibir dinero
gratis, y de hecho eso explica por qué
en mitad de esta crisis fiscal
el primer ministro japonés Shinzo Abe
hiciera esta declaración en el año
2015.
- "Japón se ve presionada a aceptar más inmigrantes ante el
hundimiento de su población activa".
Pero, ojo, porque aunque no lo parezca
este no es el mayor problema de Japón.
En realidad, el gran desafío de la
economía japonesa es lo que llaman la
"década perdida" que es que llevan 20
años sin crecer y en este caso los
inmigrantes también tienen algo que
decir
Todos imaginamos a Japón como un ejemplo de
país innovador y vanguardista.
Recordaréis compañías como Nintendo,
Toshiba o Sony
El problema es que todas esas empresas
son viejas. Nintendo fue fundada en 1889,
Toyota nació en 1937.
Es más, ¿alguno de vosotros sería capaz
de nombrarme cinco empresas japonesas
creadas en este siglo?
Seguro que os costaría una barbaridad.
Sin embargo, no tendríais ningún
problema a la hora de citarme a cinco o
incluso diez empresas norteamericanas
surgidas en los últimos diez años.
- "Los inmigrantes han fundado el 52% de
las empresas de Silicon Valley
entre 1995 y 2005".
Las tasas de emprendimiento en la población
inmigrante son entre todos y tres veces
más altas que las de la población
local y esto es una tendencia que se da
en todos los países. Por ejemplo, uno de
los fundadores de Google Serguei Brin era
un inmigrante ruso que había nacido en
Moscú; y el cofundador de WhatsApp, Jan Koum,
es ucraniano.
No sólo hablamos de las start-up de
Silicon Valley, cualquiera de los que
veis este medio desde España podéis salir
a dar una vuelta por vuestro barrio y
veréis montones de restaurantes y
tiendas chinas, de kebab paquistaníes, de
toda clase de empresas y negocios
fundados por rumanos y búlgaros.
Y, además, es que tiene bastante lógica
que los inmigrantes sean más
emprendedores. A fin de cuentas, desde el momento en
el cual dejan su país, ya están
demostrando que no tienen miedo al riesgo.
Pero, no sólo eso, además, un inmigrante
trae una cultura totalmente distinta y
por eso le resulta mucho más sencillo
aportar ideas nuevas en la economía en
la que vive.
Por ejemplo, cuando Chad Feltman llegó a
Nueva York a mediados del siglo XIX se
dio cuenta de que en esa ciudad
necesitaban comida rápida y así es
como se le ocurrió la idea de importar
salchichas de su alemania natal y crear
lo que hoy conocemos como el perrito
caliente. Hoy en día este producto da de
comer y paga las facturas de millones
de personas en todo el mundo. Y sí, ya
sé que es un ejemplo muy sencillo pero
es que podremos encontrar miles a lo
largo de la historia.
En una palabra, cuando las culturas se
mezclan surgen nuevas ideas de hacer las
cosas y nuevos métodos de trabajo.
Y esto es lo que en el mundo empresarial
se llama innovación, y ese es el
ingrediente especial para que las
economías puedan volverse más
competitivas.
De hecho, los que seguís VisualPolitik
desde hace tiempo,
recordaréis este vídeo en el que os
contábamos cómo Israel se ha
convertido en una de los mayores de
innovación del mundo entero gracias en
buena medida a su población extranjera.
Y os preguntaréis ¿qué ocurre en Japón?
Pues resulta que es el país con la
menor tasa de emprendimiento del mundo
desarrollado. Sólo un 7 por ciento de su
población emprende en comparación con
el 10 por ciento de Canadá o Nueva
Zelanda. El sueño de todo japonés no es
crear su propio negocio si no entrar a
trabajar de por vida en una de esas
grandes empresas como Sony o Toshiba.
Y, por supuesto, estas grandes corporaciones
mantienen las mismas estructuras
corporativas y los mismos métodos de
trabajo de los años 80
"- Las empresas tradicionales de electrónica como Sharp o
Sony incurrieron en tremendas pérdidas
y miles de despidos mientras Apple o
Samsung continuaban  creciendo en bolsa".
Si recordáis, hace unos meses sacabamos
otro vídeo en el que os hablábamos de los
patrocinadores de la Eurocopa 2016, y
recordábamos como hace 20 años había
como mínimo dos empresas japonesas en
la lista de sponsors. Este año no había
ninguna. Y es que da igual el sector
donde miréis. En cualquier industria,
las empresas japonesas tienen
muchísimos problemas a la hora de
competir con las firmas estadounidenses,
europeas o incluso las chinas. Y la
razón no es la falta de dinero sino la
falta de innovación y todo esto explica
por qué la economía japonesa lleva 20
años paralizada.
Y, por supuesto, no os creáis que esto no
tiene un reflejo en el día a día de
los japoneses. Para poder mantener un
mínimo de competitividad frente a las
empresas extranjeras
los trabajadores japoneses tienen los
horarios laborales más largos y las
vacaciones más cortas de toda la OCDE.
Y por supuesto siguen cobrando el mismo
sueldo prácticamente que cobraban en
los años 90.
Y la pregunta es ¿creéis que Japón debería abrir sus
puertas a la inmigración?
¿Seguís pensando que los inmigrantes son
un problema para los países que los
reciben? Podeis dejarme vuestras
respuestas en los comentarios
y no olvides que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros
al canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Como siempre si
queréis profundizar más en este tema
encontraréis varias links en la
descripción. Si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.